good afternoon our thoughts remain with
the Turkish people following last week's
devastating earthquakes
thousands of Emergency Response
Personnel from NATO allies have been
supporting the relief efforts
including with search and rescue teams
firefighters medical personnel and
seismic experts
or NATO Isle Allah to the shelter
facilities to help accommodate people
displaced by the earthquakes
you stand and stone so that with our
Ally turkey
NATO defense ministers will meet this
week at an important moment for
transatlantic security
we will take decisions
to strengthen NATO's returns and defense
we will address our industrial capacity
and increase the protection or critical
undersea infrastructure
annual step up and sustain our support
for Ukraine
almost one year since the nation
President Putin is not preparing for
peace he is launching new offenses
so we must continue to deploy Ukraine
with what he needs to win
and to achieve a just and sustainable
peace
Ukraine's defense minister Nicole will
join us tomorrow
both for the U.S led combat group for
Ukraine and for a meeting with NATO
ministers
together we will address Ukraine's
urgent needs
it is fair
that we are in a race of logistics
key capabilities like ammunition Fuel
and spare parts must reach Ukraine
before Russia can seize the initiative
on the battlefield
speed will save lives
if Putin wins in Ukraine the message to
him and other authoritarian regimes is
that force is rewarded
that would make the world more dangerous
and all of us more vulnerable
so welcome the recent announcements by
allies
on new tanks heavy weaponry and training
for Ukraine
and I look forward to further deliveries
our message is clear NATO stands with
Ukraine for as long as it takes
ministers are also addressed how to step
up our practical support for Bosna and
azzabogan Georgia and Moldova
three value native Partners which face
Russian threats
on Wednesday allies will take decisions
to further strengthen our deterrence and
events
we're all in the dumb adults placing
forty thousand troops on the NATO
command in eastern part of the alliance
but by Major era Naval power
and doubling the number of battle groups
from four to eight
now we need to ensure we have the right
forces and capabilities for the longer
term
so expect allies will agree in new
guidance for NATO defense planning
this will be a key driver of capability
changes and ensure credible deterrence
on defense in the years will come
ministers will also focus on ways to
increase our defense industrial capacity
and replenish stop oils
the war in Ukraine
is consuming an enormous amount of
ammunition
and repeating Allied supports
the current rate of Ukraine's ammunition
expenditure is mainly times higher than
our current rate of production
this puts our defense Industries under
its training
for example the waiting time for large
caliber ammunition has increased from 12
to 28 months
orders placed today would only be
delivered two and a half years later
so we need to ramp our production and
invest in our production capacity
many of us just completed an
extraordinary survey of our munition
softwars and we plan to increase our
targets for National supports to the
NATO defense planning process
the good news is that several allies
including United States and France have
already signed a new multi-year
contracts with the defense industry
enabling them to invest in increased
production capacity
I look forward to further further
progress
this is essential to ensure we can keep
supporting Ukraine while protecting
protecting every initial Allied
territory
the protection of critical ownership
infrastructure will also be high on our
agenda
NATO has been working on this for many
years and we are now taking it into the
next level
we have decided to establish a new
coordination cell at NATO headquarters
to map our vulnerabilities and engage
with industry
this will support our efforts to prevent
and counter threats to critical
infrastructure including undersea cables
and Pipelines
and leave this at the business Summit
will take further decisions to step up
our efforts in this area
we'll also work also with the European
Union to the NATO in the task force of
descendants and critical infrastructure
NATO continues to adapted all domains
including in space which is becoming
more crowded and competitive
this week I expect allies will agree to
establish a new virtual network of
national and Commercial satellites
this will improve our intelligence and
surveillance
and support intermissions and operations
it will allow allies to increase the
sharing on space-based data with enable
command structure
facilitating better navigation
communication and early warning of
missile launches
all of this work
requires continued investment in our
defense so ministers will discuss ways
to maintain and step up defense spending
across the alliance
we are under our track with eight
consecutive years who increases by
European allies time Canada
an additional 250 billion extracts spent
so far
I expect that we will see further
increases in defense spending this year
but we need to keep up momentum
our decisions this week will pave the
way for our Summit in Venus in July and
help keep our people safe in a more
dangerous world
without I'm ready to take your questions
Secretary General thank you very much
maxp just two issues you mentioned that
Putin is starting new offenses in
Ukraine do you believe that this is the
beginning of the Big Spring offensive
that you've been warning about for a
while
and then connected to the Munitions do
you how can you be so confident that
NATO will be able to keep up supplies to
Ukraine of the ammunition it needs to
face a major offensive and then as
another question on on the balloons that
we've seen
have uh is NATO stepping up its own
surveillance elsewhere around the in
Europe and other places of the balloons
and the unidentified objects that we've
seen in over North America that
um first on the ammunition well this is
an issue we started with this last air
because we saw that the enormous amount
of support for Ukraine the only way to
deliver that was to dig into our
existing stocks but of course in the
long run we don't continue to do that we
need to produce more to be able to
deliver sufficient ammunition to uh to
Ukraine but at the same time ensure that
we have enough Omission to protect and
defend all NATO allies evidence of
Allied territory so that's also the
reason why we several months ago started
this um extraordinary Auto Circle review
of our
stocks and the need to increase our
level of of
stocks meaning by by increasing the
guidelines for camping tutorial is
related to ammunition stocks and also
why allies have started to engage with
industry and several hours have already
made decisions agreed long-term
contracts with the industry so they can
run for production make the Investments
to increase Investments so I'm confident
that we are now on a flat or on a path
that will enable us to able to continue
to support Ukraine but also to reference
our own stocks and and it just shows the
importance of increasing the best
spending
um because all of this of course
requires more Defender expenditure by a
NATO allies
then on the volumes well I think what
we saw over the United States obviously
the United States last week it's part of
pattern where China but also Russia are
increasing their intelligence and
surveillance activities against native
allies with many different platforms we
see it in cyber and we see it when
satellites more and more satellites and
we see them with buttons that highlights
the importance of
our vigilance our increased presence
and also that we need a ramp up and step
up uh how we share intelligence and how
we Monitor and protect our air base and
actually one of the issues we're going
to address and decide on the on the
minister meeting tomorrow is increased
um cooperation between allies in space
sharing more data collecting more data
also from commercial satellites and then
sharing that with the NATO command
structure so that's part of overall
picture how we do more to Monitor and
and have sufficient so at this
capabilities to protect all over a space
the first question was
do you believe that this is the start of
the major Russia well I I think
realities that we are seeing the thought
already
because we see in what what Russia does
not present between you now is to send
in houses so thousands of more troops
um accepting a very high rental casualty
um taking a big losses uh but putting
pressure on ukrainians and what
Russia lacks in quality they try to
compensate in quantity meaning that the
leadership the the logistics the
equipment the the the training
don't have the same level as the
Ukrainian forces but they have more
forces
and the Russians are willing to ascend
in those forces and and take a high high
number of casualties so for me this just
behind us the importance of timing it's
urgent to provide Ukraine with more
weapons
this past we can deliver weapons
ammunition spare parts fuel to the
Ukraine in the front the more lives we
save and the the
better we support efforts to find a
peaceful negotiating solution to this
conflict
uh let's just
thank you Secretary of General as we are
approaching the first anniversary of the
invasion uh what actions do you Russia
expect to take to mark that date on
Battlefield in Ukraine and Beyond
the most important message is that we
see no sign whatsoever that a President
Putin is preparing for peace already to
negotiate something which will respect
the territorial integrity and celebrity
of Ukraine
what we see is that President Putin in
Russia
still wants to control Ukraine
um and therefore the only way to ensure
that Ukrainian prevails as a Sovereign
Nation is to continue to provide a
military support to Ukraine and I
welcome what many allies or Allies do
and have done for months
stepping up providing support to Ukraine
I'm not speculating what uh
do you own the 24th but the more
importantly is that we see how they are
sending in more troops more weapons more
capabilities to try to pressure the
opinions about how ukrainians are able
to resist understand against the Russian
erosion
foreign
[Music]
to follow up on on a couple of things on
on the balloons have have other NATO
countries started looking at whether in
fact his students have been flown over
other areas because they weren't
necessarily detected in the beginning so
is this something that uh that you think
uh would would require more
um uh sort of more research and what a
threat does it pose to Nato other than
potential intelligence gathering and
also on ammunition
um industry says that aside from a few
large contracts all of the work on him
on increasing the speed of procurement
has not actually resulted in a lot more
contracts given to them at this point so
if this if if the delay has been
extended even doubled in some cases if
you don't if you don't include a
contract even that period doesn't start
so what can you say about that thank you
so first of all we are in close dialogue
contact with the defense industry at the
Naper level I met with them and NATO
allies uh I met and engaged with the
defense industry and and there are
several contacts which are which are now
signed and you're absolutely right or
what the matters at the end of the day
is actually the signing of contracts
concrete commitments to provide more
ambition and that has started to happen
in the United States trunk but also
otherwise I don't know for instance
Norway has signed a big contract with
their ammunition uh industry to ramp of
production
of course in the short run the industry
can increase production by having
receipts by by using existing production
and Facilities more but you really have
a significant increase they need to
invest and to build a new plants and we
see a combination both of utilizing
existing capacity more and also by
making decisions to invest in increased
capacity this has started but we need
more and that's one of the reasons why
we are going to agree new guidelines for
stock price NATO guidelines and also why
we continue to engage so closely with
the defense industry to ensure that we
get the increased reproduction of
ammunitions as I said
in August last year I was actually in
Canada and I'm off as the first sector
General ever to visit a moral facility
up in our North and these are those
radar facilities that monitor and track
all their airspace uh between Russia on
the North Pole into North America and
this is actually protecting NATO this is
a vital deputies for NATO and uh NORAD
which is a joint uh
also capability that the United States
and cannot live together
they have decided to invest heavily in
modernizing that in more advanced Radars
with a better
defense capabilities and also visited a
Canadian Air Base called pain where they
have the planes that actually intercept
and and help to protect Canadian and
North American airspace so it just
finalize the importance of that we are
ramping up the strengthening and
improving our ability to defend airspace
both of North America but also in Europe
and that's exactly what we have done
over the last years with more air
policing with a better space facilities
and also that you will do at the defense
minister meeting now where allies will
come together and strengthen what they
do in space to be able to better monitor
better detect any evaluation of a NATO
Express
although and approaching to Romanian
borders but any way you know than the
Russian missiles approaching to the NATO
airspace is some kind of testing of the
air defense of NATO do you see that like
some kind of warning from a Russian side
and there's another part of the question
do you see any threats to the supply
rules uh NATO and their countries
delivering nearly support to Ukraine
thank you
Wars are dangerous dangerous things
happen every day and and of course it's
also
um dangerous because incidents and
accents may happen uh and that's exactly
why we are so Vigilant in NATO
um to prevent any escalation Beyond
Ukraine
and that's also why
um we actually before the Innovation
during last fall on the fall of 2021
we increased on the interpersons in
eastern part of the alliance also in the
vaccine region and also on the day of
the invasion we met here in the neighbor
headquarters we involved the Naples
defense plans I'm designing to further
increase some interpresence in eastern
part of the alliance with air Naval and
land capabilities we did that
uh part to be able to monitor to protect
to ensure no estimation Beyond Ukraine
and also to be able to manage in central
accidents that may occur when there's a
full visual war going on in our
neighborhood in uh in the Ukraine but of
course these military presence of NATO
troops native forces
in Poland in Romania in Slovakia in
other countries in eastern part of
Alliance also protects the space when it
allow us to support Ukraine
um and that makes it even more important
that you have increased our presence in
an instant part of the alliance NATO is
not pointed to the conflict but we
support Ukraine and we support Ukrainian
pulling the right for self-defense so
that is why the right decision showing
the new charters
[Music]
okay thank you very much
um Secretary General after president
zelenski's visit to Russia's last week
There's clearly a reinvigorated debate
now about building a coalition that
could send fighter airplanes to Ukraine
when this debate started almost a year
ago you were quite concerned and you
said that NATO would not be sending
airplanes because it would not be
interfering into the war so my question
today is do you still share these
concerns
um that it might be seen as an
interference and if not how would you
Coalition Coalition have to be built
what would be the requirements to make
this really work thank you
so first I think we need to distinguish
between the two things one thing uh is
what was discussed very much uh last
year and that was uh the issue of uh
whether NATO should establish a no-fly
zone of Ukraine and send in NATO planes
to enforce no fly song that's a very
different thing and then what is
discussed now and that is the
possibility of NATO allies uh delivery
aircraft to Ukraine so they can use
themselves that's two very very
different things because if NATO was
going to send the NATO planes to enforce
with a NATO presence in the airspace of
Ukraine and all flies on that only
direct Naval involvement
it's a very different thing to provide
the ukrainians with different types of
military capabilities
that will not make us party to the
conflict
um
um for the support Ukraine has evolved
as the award has evolved in the
beginning there was enormous focus on
javelins on at the time flight and
attack weapons and then we saw the
urgent need for uh artillery and the
Allies I started to step up the delivery
of both advanced modern artillery and
then air defense has been a main focus
and our heavy weaponry and a historical
valleys infantry fighting vehicles
um
from from Germany and also main battle
packs and it's a constant conversation
consultation process within the alliance
on what types of weapon systems we
should deliver and as you have seen from
meager there is now a
discussion going on also on the question
of aircraft
and I expect that also to be addressed
tomorrow at the meetings here in
Brussels
but let me have two things and that is
that one is
speed
urgency because whatever the opinion may
be about aircraft double their time
what is needed now is
urgent support for Ukraine so my top
priority is to ensure that the precious
allies are made for uh
infantify the vehicles for armor for uh
battle tanks that are delivered as soon
as possible because every day counts
the other thing is that yes it is
important to have a constant
consultation and an allies on what new
capsules we should provide and of course
this is evolving but in addition to
discussing new platforms we need to be
extremely focused on ensuring that the
platforms show all the delivered are
working as they should
just ensure that that air different
systems we have delivered in the
artillery we have delivered past
ammunition as the spare parts has the
maintenance as the logistics has all the
sustainment they need to do to function
is an enormous logistical task that
requires an enormous amount of of
deliveries every day so yes of course it
is important to discuss new systems but
the most urgent thing is to ensure that
all the system suits are all in there or
at all they're being pledged or
delivered and work as they should
and TV
Secretary General from antivity of
course the issue is the earthquake in
Turkey after the university
requested the assistance of eavrcc and
the adscc would rather quickly they have
decided to deploy shelters in Turkey so
my question is when these will be
operational in turkey and apparently the
list of what turkey needs is rather very
long because
being a situation to to send to Turkey
and there is also the the question of
the security the raising security
officer from the southern flank between
Syria and turkey and is there anything
that NATO could do to deliver fully this
uh
thank you
as you said the turkey also helped
through our other eurodynamic Disaster
Response mechanism very early and and
and and hours after earthquake we sent
out a code of llamas and offers to
provide support and help to Ukraine and
to Solitude after the earthquake and and
and that's exactly what others have done
while actually an important to Nato and
of course also through the European
Union and in different ways and I
welcome all those efforts that's that's
something which is extremely important
and NATO will deliver
shelters uh we will do that as soon as
possible I'm not able to give you an
exact date but but allies are NATO are
working hard to deliver us support us
quickly as as possible NATO is also
provided from transportation and I don't
think it's important both to make sure
that we get support quickly but also to
ensure that we actually are able to stay
because this will emit because earth
earthquake will have consequences for a
long time and therefore turkey and the
people that
in the region will need the support for
about time
let me just
which also have expressed thought into
the president and other one
philosophize and the devastating
consequences of the earthquake we have
seen in uh
the Associated Press
um the the war is coming up to a
virtually as one year marker and I
wonder if uh if you have any thoughts on
on how it's changed NATO and in
particular your job and and is this a
job that you want to keep doing as we
come into the into the next employees
well it won't work if that's not change
people if it's just demonstrating the
importance of people
uh and how important it has been that
actually since 2014 NATO has
implemented the biggest reinforcements
of collective defense in the generation
because the war didn't start in February
last step it started in 2014 and and
that triggered a big adaptation or
alliance with higher in the soil forces
with more presence in eastern part of
the alliance with more exercises and
also for first time in many years all
allies started to increase the defense
spending so filamental it hasn't changed
NATO it has only demonstrated the
importance of allies standing together
both in providing support to Ukraine but
also in protecting each other and
ensuring that the war doesn't escalate
beyond the Ukraine and and when we
decided the warning of the invasion to
increase our presence then we were able
to build on the increased presence we
have already implemented Over Law pairs
we decided the battle groups in 2016 and
we actually increased our business also
in the months ahead of the invasion
because the nation will no surprise this
wasn't nation in Europe was coming and
therefore we were prepared when it
happened
um
for me this extremely uh important to to
focus on my task as second General in
the morning challenge in time for the
alliance and that's what happens
thank you very much
TV this is totenberg just a quick
follow-up on the question with regard to
fighter jets do I understand you
correctly that you do not rule out those
the delivery of fighter jets
because there's some member states
especially the gentleman Johnson who
said that this is milgo due to the risk
of escalation and the second question
I'm sure you're aware of the concept
that your predecessor under strong
basmussen has developed for Ukraine he
spoke of and he promotes the idea of
security guarantees for Ukraine in the
midterm as an alternative to Nato
membership what do you think of this do
you think this is realistic and a
possibility to secure the future of
Ukraine
yes it is important sorry yes it is
possible of course to secure the future
of Ukraine uh the first thing we need to
do then is to help them to win this War
uh and that's exactly the main focus of
everything we do is to ensure sufficient
surprise uh or everything from heavy
armor to uh to you and to drones to the
fuel and non Military Support in all
forms and and checks so so that's
exactly what to do so that's the
precondition number one the second Main
focus should be that when this war ends
in one way or another
we should ensure that Ukraine is able to
deter and defend itself
because uh we'll be so after 2014 is
that uh
Ukraine was not in a position to deter a
second attack
the Russia went in and Olivia and
extremia and and then a few weeks or
months after they went into istanbulance
and then we had the war going up and
down for many years until the full
presentation
what we need now
is that we are able to strengthen
Ukraine with support with training and
it also looks into the more long-term
transformation of or transitioning of
the Ukrainian armed forces from Soviet
era doctrines and Equipment which is
still very important part of their our
forces through Modern NATO capabilities
interoperables so so Ukraine can be in
position to deter any further aggression
that's perhaps the most important thing
to secure the Ukraine in the future and
that is to enable them to have an even
stronger Armed Forces after some kind of
Peace Arrangement
that may be agreed at the end of the war
in in Ukraine to prevent a third big
attack on after 2014 after what happened
last year and then and then potentially
new one so that's the second thing is to
ensure that we work with Ukraine or
long-term
reforms long term in the probability a
long-term transition to Naval standards
and and help them to build up their
Armed Forces even more and then and then
the third issue will be the issue
whether there will be some International
Arrangements agreements uh assurances
well that may be
a part of uh some kind of negotiated
solution where are ours also participate
I'm careful speculating exactly how they
will perform right and uh and uh and and
what kind of framework there will be
issued but I'm saying that of course
some kind of arrangements where NATO
allies applied also some assurances in
different ways to impact absolutely
possible that will be part of the
overall solution to the conflict in
Ukraine to with to to maximize the
likelihood of Ukraine being able to
deter any further attacks or
Financial Times
well well I I'm not able to say that
what we have seen over one year that
close to home one year this war is that
what type of support we provide evolves
and there is a discussion discussions
about every step we have the discussion
about patrons who have the discussion
about armor we have discussion about the
factor tanks we had the discussion of
long-range uh uh High Mars and and and
this is an important assertion uh the
important thing is that NATO is not a
part of the conflict even though an
Obama's provide Advanced weapon systems
to Ukraine
we had right to support for them because
Ukraine defend themselves against the
war of Russian and then regardless of
what you think about aircraft that will
take time so we need to now at least
ensure that we deliver what we can
deliver in the short term because that
can really make a difference on the
battlefield in the community
other footprints
thank you so much
I wanted to ask
from what you've said it doesn't sound
like this is a solvable problem if
you're using it faster than we can build
every time's a doubling as you just said
and we can't just give them new
factories how do we solve that then or
oh yeah
right now Ukraine is out of ceiling what
can be provided
by later
and non-nato allies
um are we at that point already
so what I said also the current rate of
ammunition consumption is higher bigger
than the current rate of production
that's a factual thing
but since we have been aware of that for
some time we have started to do
something we don't just sit in there I
will and watching this happening so
that's the reason why we're over several
months have uh worked hard I think
though and also in the Ramstein format
to ramp up production that's the reason
why we launched this out of circle
extraordinary review of our third points
when we have collected the data and now
we're using this data to work individual
analysis and work with them to design
contracts with uh with the industry and
that's exactly what they do
uh and of course the industry has the
capability to increase the production
also shorter sometimes there's some some
uh non-used or not utilize the uh
capability there but even when you have
Factory running you can have more shifts
you can even work in weekends this is an
issue of cost and price and then you
need of course to invest in new
Russian
capability and that's also what they do
especially when they uh CNC can have a
multi-air contracts and we've seen
several examples of our signing
multi-air contracts and then the
industry have the demands in the need to
make the Investments so yes we have a
challenge yes we have a problem but
problems are there to be solved and we
are investing that problem and we have
strategies to solve it both in a short
from your term to as a mobilize defense
industry and if there's anything made by
allies and our economists our societies
have approved over decades is that we
are Dynamic and we are adaptable we can
change when needed so if you just send a
clear signal and also mobilize the
financial resources as we are doing with
our pledge to invest more than the
industry are proven extremely capable of
producing uh more and that those are of
course this is the challenge of having
enough ammunition is also a big
challenge for uh for uh Russia
so it just shows that this is a world of
efficient and the water attrition
becomes a battle of the logistics and we
focus on the logistical part of the
defense capacity
production
my name is
Secretary General most of the ocean
Nation does not support the Russian
separation against Ukraine
which is why location regime did not
decide to openly participate in
regression but only supports it what is
the latest position on his on this
complicity of the location regime does
need to separate the political regime
from the Russian Society
yes so we are aware that empowers is not
a democracy we are aware that that the
regime
um in in means goes to represent the
people of of Belarus
because they're also seeing how uh the
elections were totally manipulated and
the election is also not respected so so
we are aware that that the people of
Earth they have a very different opinion
about the war than the regime and of
course the regime is complicit in
Russia's illegal War because even though
there's not sent in their own troops
they have allowed the President Putin in
Russia to use the Earth as a platform to
launch attacks against uh against
Ukraine you can remember at the
beginning of the war that the date
Invasion started actually the forces
came in from the north from Belarus
trying to take Ikea and the territory in
the in the North
it continues to be used for air and
Alissa attacks and also the joint
exercises of course is a challenge for
the ukrainians of the exercises between
girls and and the version and Russian
forces so so so the the the
[Music]
Russian regime should not be complicit
should should not support uh Russia's
illegal Warriors versus Blade modulation
of international law and and something
that alsoever should of course conduct
um
thank you uh I I understand that the the
support of fighter aircrafts to Ukraine
that's not the highest priority but the
discussion is ongoing in the great soil
we will start training pilots and there
are countries that's not ruining at all
so Mrs Senator General will you speak in
favor of it or will you war against it
and my second question is about uh
they need to websites that were taken
down over the weekend it might have been
uh Target or like Cyber attack over the
weekend you can really respect yourself
as a cyberspace is contested
um in all times and we Face a NATO
malicious cyber activities on a daily
basis and we are strengthening our cyber
defenses uh so this is something we have
responded to over uh many years because
we have seen more and more uh different
types of cyber attacks uh malicious
cyber activities against our networks
and we have seen some attempted denial
of service incidents against a number of
NATO websites on since Sunday
additional protective measures are being
put in place and the majority websites
are the functioning now as a normal
some native websites are still
experiencing availability
uh issues about our technical teams are
now working to restore full access then
it is extremely important to understand
the following
our classified networks the networks we
use to communicate between NATO
emissions of operation and NATO within
the NATO command structure
were not affected and there is currently
no evidence or the impact on map
operations so one thing is a public
uh uh uh uh Pages or or
sites where we actually share the
information with a with a role outside
the NATO uh there have been attempt uh
to have deniable services
so I keep this against those pages but
Naples classified the network has not
been that
great
okay thank you for the floor uh Mr
Secretary General the words of former
Italian prime ministers have caused
America in Italy he said he would not go
to the landscape if he were prime
minister now because he had talked to
dependent republics of the combats and
the Bible should force him to a truth
and neither is uncomfortable see these
statements as pure crime in propaganda
and the problem is that personal
practice part of the government
correlation so are you afraid that if we
could be
to be seen as the pollution salt on
their belly and are you satisfied with
them yesterday Aid provided to Kia who
could roll do more
first of all I met with uh
took office a few months ago and the
message from her was very clear I also
met with the foreign minister the
defense minister defense minister it
will be here tomorrow and and the
message from the Italian government is
absolute support to Ukraine and foreign
and France are now working together to
deliver the advanced air defense systems
some team which is a Italian French
joint effort so so I'm absolutely that
it will remain a strong supporter of
NATO's strong support to Ukraine uh not
least because it understands us
allowance understand that this is about
our city
it'll be a tragedy for ukrainians if
president Britain wins but it will also
be dangerous for us to make us more
vulnerable because a message to him
alone he gets what he wants